buona serata
mi chiamo guido baron cintura
sono un ingegnere ambientale per molti
anni mi sono occupato di idrogeologia
sistemi informativi geografici
telerilevamento negli ultimi tre anni ho
concentrato la mia attenzione su bitcoin
e le monete matematiche e cercherò di
spiegarvi stasera perché per molte
persone bitcoin è l'invenzione più
rivoluzionaria di questo secolo la prima
volta che ho conosciuto bitcoin che ho
saputo di bitcoin era il 2011
lessi un articolo di giornale che
recitava la bolla di bitcoin è esplosa
lì per lì non ci fece molto caso non
interessavo di economia le bolle sono
qualcosa di negativo quindi lasciar
stare non lestini anche l'articolo due
anni dopo nel 2013
lessi un articolo con un titolo
praticamente identico la bolla del
bitcoin è scoppiata una gravissima
com'è possibile che due bolle po strano
che una bolla possa scoppiare due volte
e quindi iniziai a indagare a studiare
di più è la prima cosa che fece è
cercare un grafico che rappresentasse
l'andamento di bitcoin nel tempo quindi
scoprire che nel 2010 quali va 4
centesimi per poi arrivare a 30 dollari
nel 2011 per poi riscendere a tre
risalire e così via in una scala
logaritmica che rappresenta meglio
queste queste funzioni così in
particolari notari che aveva sì un
andamento crescente ma con una
volatilità enorme e voglio capire di più
perché la gente voleva questi bitcoin e
iniziai a leggere articoli su articoli
per giorni lesse articoli la prima cosa
che salta subito all'occhio forse la una
delle più importanti è che il numero di
bitcoin è limitato mai se ne potranno
creare più di 21 milioni
voi direte una cosa di poco conto ma se
ci riflettiamo fino al 2009 cioè prima
della creazione di bitcoin tutti tutti i
beni digitali tutte le cose digitali
erano replicabili se avevamo un file
musicale ne potevamo fare quante copie
volevamo
i bitcoin è l'invenzione che riesce a
riprodurre la scarsità nel mondo
digitale e questo è la la spinta la
molla che spinge le persone a volere un
pezzettino di bitcoin e alcune persone
pensano addirittura che sia migliore
dell'oro perché facciamo un passo
indietro torniamo all'impero romano
da allora e per duemila anni il potere
di emettere moneta era in mano a
imperatori e governi imperatori che per
secoli hanno mentito ai propri sudditi
sulla quantità di oro e argento che era
presente all'interno delle monete e
governi che per motivi politici motivi
economici ma anche motivi militari
aumentavano anche a dismisura la
quantità emessa di moneta con la
conseguente diminuzione di potere
d'acquisto dei soldi di tutti i
cittadini con bitcoin questo diventa del
tutto obsolescente perché perché bitcoin
è un software open source quindi tutti
possono vedere quello che ci sta dietro
come funziona
e questo software riguardo alle missioni
monetaria dice qualcosa di molto chiaro
ovvero che l'emissione di bitcoin è
prefissata e immutabile ed è trasparente
quindi niente cose tipo quantità divisi
in gala mario draghi e questo viene
totalmente eliminato è un'altra cosa che
scoprì le già dovesse articoli area che
il suo creatore era satoshi nakamoto uno
sviluppatore che rimaneva nell'anonimato
perché questo perché tutte le persone
che prima di lui o anche gruppi di
persone che avevano cercato di proporre
dei sistemi alternativi di moneta erano
stati individuati e neutralizzati dai
poteri centrali quindi quello che
bisognava fare era agire nell'ombra fino
a che il sistema non fosse stato
sufficientemente
decentralizzato sufficientemente
utilizzato da poter essere
effettivamente considerato resiliente
contro qualsiasi tipologia di attacco
tornando al paragone con loro altra
grossa comodità di bitcoin è che è
possibile trasferirlo da una parte
all'altra del mondo in maniera quasi
istantanea e anche il confronto con i
sistemi bancari tradizionali e ci
ritroviamo con un algoritmo un
protocollo che funziona anche di notte
durante i week end e 24 ore su 24 7
giorni su 7
quindi si può definire bitcoin come una
moneta digitale sperimentale
decentralizzata che ha la capacità di
trasferire valore a chiunque e ovunque
nel mondo
altra cosa che come abbastanza
sorprendente che è estremamente facile
ovvero uno basta che scarica una app
gratuita oppure un software gratuito e
già è pronto per riceverli se li vuole
inviare deve scarica deve scannerizzare
il qr code dell'indirizzo ricevente
decidere la quantità e nel giro di dieci
minuti
dall'altra parte del mondo questi
bitcoin sono a loro volta spendibili e
una cosa importante tutte queste
transazioni dal 2009 ad oggi tutte
nessuna esclusa sono contenute
all'interno della block chain un libro
mastro un database che ha la proprietà
di essere completamente visibile a tutti
e è completamente decentralizzato ovvero
non esistono migliaia di copie su
migliaia di computer in giro per il
mondo
altra cosa
in ciascuna di queste piccole
transazioni monetarie ci sono 80 byte
una piccolissima quantità
in questi 80 byte ciascuno
chi fa una transazione può inserire
delle informazioni lì dentro si chiama
opere torna questa funzione
voi direte beh insomma poca cosa 80 byte
che cosa ci si può fare però
ricordiamoci che sono 80 byte
all'interno di una struttura
indistruttibile e indelebile quindi ci
ritroviamo con un libro di storia
scritto in maniera condivisa trasparente
e indistruttibile
voi che cosa ci fareste beh vi dico che
cosa stanno facendo alcune star tappa
adesso in giro per il mondo
alcune fra cui anche italiane hanno
pensato che sarebbe possibile
disintermediare alcune istituzioni
importanti come la siae o come gli
uffici brevetti di tutto il mondo e
quindi stanno lavorando per creare dei
servizi alternativi che utilizzano la
bruxelles di bitcoin per permettere
questo altre startup stanno cercando di
risolvere un altro problema molto
interessante non monetario ovvero quello
del voto elettronico
voi sapete che ogni anno in italia
spendiamo più di 300 mil ben ogni anno
perché ci abbiamo le elezioni ogni anno
per ogni tornata elettorale costa 300
milioni di euro e ci sono delle startup
che stanno cercando utilizzare dalla
tecnologia blog chain per permettere un
voto elettronico sicuro trasparente ma
che mantenga la privacy per chi sta
donando quello che a me a noi è stato
più a cuore è stato considerato più
interessante di questa tecnologia
appunto la trasparenza e abbiamo pensato
che cosa succederebbe se le
organizzazioni che ricevono donazioni
potessero offrire ai propri donatori la
possibilità di vedere effettivamente che
cosa fanno con questi soldi cosa
succederebbe se un donatore potesse
decidere a quale organizzazione mandarli
a vedere effettivamente che cosa sta
facendo quindi decisi di prendermi un po
di tempo per scegliere le persone adatte
a questo progetto insieme disegniamo
questa piattaforma per la trasparenza
a favore dei donatori il primo problema
che ci si fosse davanti era che i
portafogli bitcoin più classici hanno
una sola password quindi non sono
particolarmente adatti alle
organizzazioni lng quindi abbiamo
sviluppato una tipologia di portafogli
più sicura che permette che evitasse la
possibilità di inside job di furti del
fatto che qualcuno si possa perdere una
chiave quindi dei portafogli di
tipologia chiamati multi siglatura molti
firma altra cosa degli strumenti creare
degli strumenti per le organizzazioni
che potessero utilizzare quel opere
torna che abbiamo visto prima quindi che
potessero facilmente inserire le
informazioni riguardo alle cose che
comprano i beni servizi che comprano i
per i loro progetti inserirli
all'interno della block chain questo è
un esempio dell'ultimo un terremoto che
è avvenuto in italia il mese scorso il
24 agosto
e qui daremo la possibilità ai donatori
di filtrare le organizzazioni che
ricevono le donazioni in funzione dei
vari parametri come il livello di trust
la trasparenza all'area dove è avvenuto
l'evento
a questo punto le organizzazioni
decideranno il loro livello di
trasparenza su e decideranno se
utilizzare gli strumenti per inserire le
informazioni all'interno della block
chain successivamente i donatori
potranno effettivamente vedere con i
nostri strumenti che cosa succede
all'interno della brucia in come si
spostano questi soldi il problema della
trasparenza un problema che esiste anche
in altri settori come quello
assicurativo nel settore assicurativo
quello che stiamo cercando di fare sono
degli smart contract dei contratti
intelligenti che saranno in grado di
spostare in caso non lo stiamo facendo
per i terremoti in questo momento di
spostare il bullo fans le polizze che
sono all'interno di questo fondo comune
in maniera automatica e trasparente in
funzione di parametri quindi se l'utente
si trova hicks chilometri dall'epicentro
di magnitudine y e con caratteristiche
riguardo agli edifici di un determinato
tipo riceverà una determinata quantità
di denaro
come vedete le persone cercano sempre
più indipendenza e libertà e noi come le
altre start up di questo settore abbiamo
una visione comune che è quella di
mettere al centro gli utenti cittadini e
offrire un mondo più decentralizzato e
trasparente grazie